o grupo só 21 mais um vídeo e hoje
continuar a fazer estava de elástico
aqui ao contrário das últimas duas
torres nenhum canal sbt para gestante
life que não lá ficou dois elásticos
convence nem aí nós nos vídeos e
anterior sobral é de lá que eu vou fazer
uma pequena demonstração vejam que eu
vou largar e eu quero o próximo clássico
pois é que pará através do sol para
vocês fazerem estavam a gostar de coisas
muito simples mesmo que o campinho do
chinês cartão é que uma palhinha das
coisas que você governo tutorial é ficou
muito vai mesmo explicadinho isso vocês
não encontra ninguém usa e cobra
exportação podem alojar nos olhos sem os
óculos podem brincar à vontade embora
não só portugal só pra vocês quiserem
estaremos com vocês acabaram de ver no
teste coisas muito básicas
é complicado mas na verdade não eu
sempre fiquei ao máximo
então pronto por cola
deste lado e claro outros
é fazer peneira
depois pressione sobre a mesa
folha qual a nossa glória mesa só pra
ficar tudo bem alinhada que só esta
parte que a gente trata a esticar se
para votar está agora eu vou colar e
isto cá dentro
está mas somente agora eu vou cortar um
conflito com 25 de maio até 12 em 30 de
maio
agora só vou estar no sítio certo a bola
a passar por aqui
e deixar esse cara
enquanto estes apps álvaro palito
aproveitar este que terá que apostar que
os 235 importante porque a frente para
baixo assim
com isso a chance com mais ou menos
agora pode acompanhar no elástico
vamos forçar esta conexão aqui quatro
frágil ela que só é tanta coisa só eu
falar aqui de volta dessa estrutura
agora esta parte que falta aqui deste
lado meu lápis sem marcação agora vou
cortar só para reforçar este está aqui
porque é um caso fácil e mais camadas
que vai ficar mais forte para fazer o
mesmo por esse lado
a idéia é só você soubesse que seria um
crime city
vocês podem fazer você gostou
como é óbvio
vamos avançar mas está quase feita nas
duas pedrinhas pronta daqui com um
pedaço da caveira
as coisas em que protestavam
agora estavam por aqui num pedacinho
lixo
por isso para diminuir o atrito entre o
elástico que a parte que vai ficar aqui
nunca tive a chininha entra e foi
empurrando até aqui para ver só vamos
ter que usar plástico ok uma maneira
diferente a atenção para não fazer muito
mais para ver quem chega aqui mais para
baixo
mesmo assim argolas
agora é só entrar aqui por baixo
para chegar à frente
chega atrás e agora mais uma coisa está
feito mas a gente não cuidar das
fronteiras que 34 centros e agora vamos
colar
só tenho conhecimento em ficar no mesmo
nível disse
porém por um província
só mais uma coisa quando se está ao
mesmo nível mas uma coisa muito
importante só o tempo vai para trás
então você não vai à escola e não por
aqui atrás passa por cima de joão pessoa
e assim o vosso projecto vai aguentar
muito mais tempo
já está feito agora vou deixar os carros
vocês já viram como isto funciona
só espero que o estado tem conseguido
fazer isso for o caso e plantou se você
está mesmo nas façanha e voz favorito
cresce de maneira que vocês dão bicas do
conteúdo que vocês gostam e querem
continuar a fazer procana é isso que eu
vou estar com vocês devem procurar
também os elásticos nesta área
então já que wellington só por esta aqui
não só para trabalhar e deixar aqui
minha
nesta perspectiva e vão pisar aqui vão
passar por esta parte aqui do nosso ver
a tela fica aqui eu acho eu acho que
aqui
aqui vocês vão dar a volta a isto aqui é
só encaixar na bahia
quando vocês vão fazer várias vezes até
conforme o número de lares em que vocês
quiserem colocar explosão muitos também
não vai dar aquele toque como não podem
mais dão certo e que eu acho que
clássico você não pode estar só vamos só
aqui e deixar aqui né
a linha foi só do esperado
depois de fazer um movimento feito
parando para o canal inscreva-se das
atividades que vocês podem vir a custar